the Mega Millions jackpot climb even  higher overnight meaning the prizes in  both major US lotteries are now more  than 400 million dollars each no one  matched all six winning Mega Millions  numbers in last night's 361 million  dollar jackpot  they were 142 47 64 and 70 and the Mega  Ball was 22 the jackpot jumped to 418  million dollars the next drawing is  Friday the drawing for the 444 million  dollar Powerball jackpot is tonight  estimated odds of winning both one in 75  quadrillion that is 75 followed by 15  zeros so I guess that means there's hope  yet right I like your lottery enough  Never Say Never  I like the lottery I know I know well  good it's exciting yes exciting for a  lot of people odds are really against